[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
sport numéro 40 allez c'est parti comme
tous les lundi pour un nouveau tour de
lactu sport du département en 26 minutes
13S à la mode chez les filles le rollur
derby est un sport spectaculaire qui
vient des États-Unis les règles deux
équipes montées sur patin en roulette
s'affrontent au corps à corps découverte
à suivre après l'interview choc de
Stéphane paysan nous avons voulu
connaître le point de vue de la
présidente de la S montinan Ball sur le
départ de l'entraîneur en Montin nous
reviendrons dans ce 78 sport sur la
performance plutôt mitigée des joueuses
d'él encour au critérium fédéral de
national une de tennis de table
évidemment en fin d'émission comme
d'habitude tous les résultats du weekend
mais tout d'abord nous partons en
Malaisie pour le raid de l'Arbre
[Applaudissements]
Vert
Servan Gabillon vous nous aviez promis
il y a quelques semaines de nous
raconter votre raide de l'Arbre Vert
2013 vous êtes là comme premis bonsoir à
vous bonsoir vous êtes rentré le 28
novembre dernier de Malaisie une belle
île avec une belle 10e place sur près de
90 équipes engagé sur cette édition 2013
vous êtes plutôt satisfaite de cette
place à l'arrivée oui dans le top 10
c'était pas dans notre objectif au
départ donc on est contente on améliore
d'une place par rapport à l'année
dernière ou vous étiez 11e en 2012 et
21e en en 2010 en 2011 pardon donc il y
avait quand même il y a quand même une
belle progression oui même si on on
était 5e jusqu'à la dernière épreuve et
qu'on perd 5 places au classement
général sur la dernière épreuve parce
qu'on on rate un fléchage au sol en VTT
donc on fait un petit tour gratuit de
Lille jusqu'au départ du ferry ou
j'allais y venir en fait ça a été un peu
la catastrophe entre guillemets sur la
dernière épreuve vous étiez bien placé
ouais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans
cette épreuve de biathlon ben en fait on
était super bien au BTT on était
heureuse et on était devant et puis il y
avait personne devant nous pour nous
ouvrir la route et l'équipe
l'organisation nous double en moto en
nous faisant un petit signe en nous
disant allez les filles et tout et puis
au moment où il nous double par la
droite il nous cache un fléchage au sol
et eux prennent le carrefour à gauche
donc nous on les suit bêtement et en
fait ils allaient récupérer un petit
chemin de traverse pour pour le CP de
l'étable de l'étable de trek et nous on
les a suivi et puis après on les a perdu
évidemment parce que ils ont bifurqué et
on a continué continué jusqu'à ce qu'on
se rende compte que on était plus du
tout sur le sur la bonne route donc on
perd 15 minutes et sur un parcours de 30
km de VTT roulant c'est énorme bah c'est
foutu l'épreuve la plus difficile sur ce
raid c'était c'était quoi cette année
bah c'était celle-là parce que
psychologiquement quand on fait tout au
mental et que on est motivé qu'on a
donné le meilleur de soi-même faire une
erreur comme ça
d'inattention c'est c'est ça coupe les
jambes ça coupe le moral moi j'arrivais
pas justement si si moi je v vachement
de mal et mes coéquipières m'ont bien
remonté le moral et elles m'ont dit si
tu le fais pas pour toi fais-le pour
nous donc elles ont raison et j'ai
finalement on a finalement réussi on a
remonté un peu de place mais on finit
48e de l'épreuve je crois et là là
c'était difficile à accepter petite
baisse au classement personnellement je
crois que vous détestez aussi un petit
peu en tout cas le trek c'est pas votre
épreuve favorite non non non le trek
c'est pas c'est pas ce que je préfère
moi et euh en revanche cette année les
17 km de trek se sont très bien passés
pour nous j'ai bien j'ai bien couru
j'étais toujours en cordé he par mes
deux moteurs
mais voilà mais en fait comme on a
commencé le raid par par lesépreuve de
canoé et qu'on a fait un podium ça donne
un bon moral et cetera et puis et puis
du coup moi j'arrive à me remettre
mentalement dans l'état d'esprit du
canoé pour rien lâcher parce que en
canoé c'est plutôt ma force donc j'ai
essayer de retrouver cet esprit là en
trek et comme le mental joue beaucoup
dans une course bon ben là ça ça s'est
bien passé j'ai même pris du plaisir à
courir c'est énorme pour moi depuis le
retour de Malaisie vous n'avez pas le le
Red blues un petit peu un peu j'avoue
que c'est difficile de se remettre au
travail de temps en temps on repasse un
coup sur les photos du raid on
communique pas mal via facebook avec les
avec les raideuses prévoit une petite
soirée jeudi prochain voilà pour se
retrouver l'édition 2013 en Malaisie
c'était votre trè participation au raid
de l'Arbre Vert parmi les trois éditions
que auxquelles vous avez participé
l'année dernière lil Maurice notamment
qui était aussi un bel endroit avant
c'était la Guyane laquelle des trois
avez-vous préféré
euh je pense que c'était la Malaisie
parce que ça réunissait tout ce qu'on
avait eu dans les deux précédents
c'est-à-dire de la mangrove Cang Guyane
de la gingle qui a pas trop à l'île
Maurice et puis des lagons et des mers
magnifiques comme comme Maurice pour le
coup voilà ces petites îles là dans
lesquelles on navigue au milieu
desquelles on navigue c'est c'est
magnifique et et puis ajouter à cela il
y a la population malaise qui qui est
adorable qui nous encourage B rencontre
justement sur le sur la route j'ai
rencontré des
singes c'est une rencontre oui oui oui
oui non mais c'est sympa de courir avec
les macaques le long de en fait en canoé
sur la première épreuve à un moment il y
avait pas assez d'eau donc on a été
obligé de descendre du canoé les deux
coéquipières ont poussé le canoué dans
l'eau et moi je suis allé courir sur le
banc de sable et là il y avait plein de
maquque sur le ban de sable qui courit
avec moi c'était sympa et sinon des
belles rencontres bah l'avantage de
l'Asie c'est que il y a des massages
partout donc bah on peut se faire masser
après les et les ÉU les massages sont un
peu tendus quand
même vous êtesevenu en un seul morceau
de toute façon ça va oui on a eu de la
chance personne s'est blessé pas dans
notre équipe en tout cas voilà ouais le
R de larbre vert c'était aussi une
occasion pour vous de faire un un peu
d'humanitaire je sais que vous courez
pour une association oui on court depuis
2 ans pour l'association toutes à
l'école qui parenne des petites filles
au Cambodge pour leur donner accès à
l'éducation parceque la majorité des des
problèmes sociétaux là-bas sont dû à au
fait que les petites filles vont pas à
l'école donc peuvent pas travailler donc
se font un peu exploiter par donc voilà
c'est un système de parrainage on donne
de l'argent pour qu'elle puisse aller
dans des écoles cette expérience de du
ça a renforcé les liens qu'il y avait au
sein de votre équipe j'imagine que
c'était les mêmes coéquipières que
l'année dernière ouais c'est les mêmes
coéquipières depuis 3 ans ben ça
renforce tout le temps en fait c'est des
expériences à chaque fois qui peuvent
être douloureuses ben quand voilà comme
sur la dernière épreuve et puis des
grosses joies on a fait deux podiums sur
le sur le raid donc pendant les les
épreuves c'était c'était c'est sympa et
puis après au sein des équipes on a une
bonne on en connaît beaucoup maintenant
il y a une bonne entente on cent TR
toutes voilà c'est très bien merci
beaucoup Servin d'être passé sur le 78
sport et puis peut-être à l'année
prochaine ou l'année d'après c'est on
jamais pour de nouveau raid en tout cas
merci à vous très à la mode chez les
filles j'en parlais dans les titres de
cette émission en ce moment le rollur
derby est un sport spectaculaire qui
vient des États-Unis les règles deux
équipes montées sur patin à roulette
s'affrontent au corps à corps découverte
avec les sucubes premier club des
lines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
spectacle tenue extravagante vitesse une
chose est sûre les filles du rollur
derby n'ont peur de rien sur leur patin
roulette le contact est souvent violent
les chutes très fréquentes effectivement
il y a un petit côté
déjanté il y en a plusieurs qui ont des
cheveaux de couleur les percings les
tatouages c'est un sport qui c'est assez
décalé moi j'avais envie de reprendre un
sport de combat au départ et en même
temps c'était trop discipliné pour moi
là il y a de la musique il y a la
plaisir de la glisse il y a le plaisir
de se mettre des coups aussi et puis bah
après on va voir une VIè avec les
copines des tribunes cela pourrait
ressembler à une énorme mêlée pourtant
la règle du jeu est très simple la
jamuse dotée d'une étoile sur le casque
doit marquer des points en dépassant les
bloqueuses de l'équipe adverse prête à
tout pour la faire
chuter le rur derby c'est aussi
l'occasion idéale d'oublier à la mode
américaine les complexes et le quotidien
pour les filles le défouloir c'est c'est
super important c'est un sport de fille
avant tout donc elles ont besoin de
s'exprimer voilà sur le track sur la
piste et puis après quand ell rentrent B
elle s'occupe de leur petite famille on
a beaucoup de mères de famille même si
on n'est pas forcément des gantés à
l'extérieur on devient ici par l'esprit
par le sport d'équipe et puis c'est un
sport américain donc il y a tout tout un
peu un show américain autour et ça
permet aussi justement nous externaliser
pour leur premier match officiel face au
lil roller girls les sucubes ne l'ont
pas emporté mais nul doute qu'elles
continueront encore longtemps de se
battre sur leur
[Musique]
rôle après l'interview Chock de Stéphane
paysan que nous diffusions la semaine
dernière dans le dans le 78 sport nous
avons voulu connaître le point de vue de
la présidente de la S Montin B Marie
José gafroid sur le départ de
l'entraîneur enimtin on l'écoute Marie
José gaefro vous bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente de la S Montini enbal merci
déjà de passer dans le 78 sport merci
bonsoir et merci de me recevoir euh tout
d'abord pour que les téléspectateur et
un peu le contexte de votre intervention
je vous propose qu'on revienne un petit
peu au début de saison quand Stéphane
paysan donc a ses problèmes de santé
c'est donc l'entraîneur de l'équipe une
du club en National 2 il doit s'arrêter
évidemment à cause de ses ennuis de
santé que décidez-vous à ce moment-là
alors donc je reçois un SMS de la part
de Stéphane paysan m'indiquant euh qui
l' arrête donc parce que suite à des
problèmes de santé donc moi je lui
réponds par un SMS en lui disant bah
écoute stphan il y a pas de souci est-ce
que tu as prévu quelque quelque chose
pour les entraînements et les managerat
pendant ton intérim et là il me renvoie
un SMS en me disant tu ne m'as pas
compris ce n'est pas de l'intérim c'est
définitif d'accord donc dès le départ
voilà dès départ de son côté c'était
définitif après 15 jours à 3 semaines
après il fait savoir
que ça va mieux et qu'il serait
susceptible de revenir d'accord à ce
moment-là donc par la personne qui
m'indique cette information je dis ben
écoute je vois pas d'inconvénient mais
j'aimerais qu'il m'appelle avant pour
qu'on en discute j'attends toujours son
coup de fil et quand il déclare qu'il ne
peut plus bon à cause de ces problèmes
de santé qu'on connaît vous décidez donc
de de prendre quelqu'un en intérime
évidemment parce qu'il faut bien
entraîner l'équipe dans la personne de
Philippe Le en fait on prend pas
quelqu'un par un terrible c'està-dire
qu'on essaie de trouver le plus
rapidement possible parce que on le sait
le le lundi ou le dimanche je crois que
c'est le dimanche d'ailleurs il y a un
match le samedi donc en une semaine il
faut qu'on mette en place une
organisation donc là on voit avec les
personnes qui sont déjà en face et
notamment avec Philippe létrange qui est
l'entraîneur de nos moins 18 qui a du
vécu en de balistique qui a en fait
toutes les compétences et les qualités
pour assurer ce rôle et heureusement
pour nous d'ailleurs il accepte et donc
du coup il part donc sur cet intérim dès
le départ pour vous c'était un intérim
on va dire long ou vous pensiez dans
votre tête à vous que
justement bah Stéphane réintégrerait
l'équipe après cesonnu de santé ou pas
pour moi au départ Stéphan c'était
définitif donc Philippe c'était plus de
l'intérim en essayant de trouver une
autre solution parce que déjà il
s'occupaent des - 17 des-1 donc ça
faisait quand même un peu beaucoup et
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas trop saturer
nos entraîneurs parce que sinon après
risque d'y avoir un petit un petit
ralbol donc au départ c'était bah pour
nous laisser le le temps de nous
retourner pour essayer de trouver un
entraîneur extérieur chose que vous
n'avez pas réussi à trouver en tout cas
un H quelqu'un que vous n'z pas réussi à
trouver voilà et donc du coup comme
après tout s'est mis en place
relativement vite et que Philippe a
accepté d'assumer ce rôle là et ben du
coup on a laissé tel que c'est on parle
on est parti là-dessus donc au moment
entre guillemets où donc Philippe
létrange prend fonction on va dire au
officiellement et le moment il y a
quelques semaines où Stéphane a
peut-être redonné un peu signe de vie
pendant ce moment-là comment ça se
passait vous vous n'iez aucune nouvelle
de Stéphane paysan personnellement je
n'en avais pas d'accord donc sa
collaboration était considérée comme
terminé à la S Montine mal voilà pour
moi en tout cas oui comme il m'avait pas
appelé pour donner suite éventuellement
à sa possibilité de retour après je sais
qu'il est resta en contact avec
certaines personnes d'accord qui
notamment lui ont proposé certaines
choses mais toute façon il fallait quand
même qu'il m'appelle avant du côté du
club à aucun moment il ne lui a été dit
bah d'accord mais du coup on ne compte
plus du tout sur toi c'est terminé non
voilà non non pas du tout parce que de
de son côté Stéphan Payson dit qu'en fin
de compte il y a eu un il y a eu
l'impression d'un kiproco que tout le
monde ne sa'est pas compris est-ce que
il y a eu un petit kiproco des on va
dire un sms alors après il y a eu
peut-être des problèmes de
communication on sait très bien vous
êtes en plus dans la communication donc
vous savez bien que on est pas
communiquant c'est un peu différent mais
on va dire qu'on on y touche un petit
peu quand même voilà donc peut-être
qu'après il y a eu des maladresses mais
euh mais en tout cas ce que je regrette
c'est que Stéphane m''est pas appelé
pour qu'on puisse en discuter tous les
deux il y a vo il a un sentiment de
d'inachevé de de regret sur cette fin
d'expérience parce que ça faisait quand
même 5 saisons que Stéphane était au
club tout tout à fait parce qu'en plus
moi j'ai toujours eu des très bon
rapport avec Stéphane ça s'est toujours
très bien passé c'est vrai que comme il
disait bon même si on a toujours eu des
les jeunes filles qui étaient en
sélection il a quand même un petit peu
plus accès sur la formation donc c'est
vrai que de avec son arrivé maintenant
on a forcément des équipes jeunes en
régional donc c'est vrai qu'il nous a
poussé vers une certaine voie et c'est
dommage c'est dommage que ça se termine
comme ça mais problème de oui je pense
que c'est un problème de communication
est-ce que dans un jour ou dans une
saison on va dire peut-être dans 5 ans
on pourrait revoir Stéphan paysan ou on
va dire que le divorce est prononcé
entre guillemets en tout cas pour moi
euh il y a pas de divorce prononcé euh
oui pourquoi pas dans un avenir pourquoi
pas avec un projet quelque chose il y a
pas de souci j'ai pas un problème avec
la personne aucun l'avenir on va dire
plus proche c'est désormais donc avec
Philippe l'étrange comment vous voyez
cette saison qui va arriver du coup
parce que là elle est un peu spéciale
hein pour l'équipe pour l'équipe une en
Nationale 2
euh bien ben nous allons nous maintenir
comme tous les ans j'ai envie de dire
prquement voilà bon ce qui est pas mal
quand même on est en National 2 et on va
travailler pour pour les saisons futures
parce que c'est vrai que là cette année
on a eu quelques départs notamment
Conand j'ai de maternité donc bon ben
c'est un groupe à recréer donc on a eu
des nouvelles arrivées mais il faut le
temps il faut le temps que ça se fasse
bah il relève déjà un peu la tête le
groupe depuis quelques matchs voilà
c'est ça donc il faut que la mayonnaise
prenne et puis c'est vrai que là elles
ont fait énormément de déplacements à
l'extérieur enfin les déplacements c'est
généralement à l'extérieur mais bon et
euh à partir du mois de janvier il y
aura plein de matchs à domicile donc
elles seront beaucoup moins fatiguées
parce que bon ce sont tous des des
amateurs donc elles ont leur métier
elles s'entraînent trois fois par
semaine après elles vont F en
déplacement à hasbrook à plouvon en
divisio donc ça
[Musique]
use une interview évidemment enregistrée
il y a quelques jours vendredi dernier
avec Marie-josé godeefroid et l'en cours
accueiller ce weekend le second tour
tour du créérium fédéral de nationalul
féminine en tennis de table tournoi
qualificatif he pour les championnats de
France 2014 en individuel les joueuses
professionnel et en courtoise étaient en
LCE évidemment pour obtenir leur ticket
pour les phases finales contre-rendu de
leur performance avec Patrick Jacques de
dixmud yannanang semble bien seule sur
les tables des phases finales pourtant
avec quatre joueuses de probé en Liss et
encour affichait ses ambitions lors du
second tour du critérium fédéral mais
après un mois de blessure Anne Sophie
Jean retrouve la
ober par rapport à la concurrence je me
suis pas beaucoup entraîné c'était
retrouver des sensations pour aussi me
préparer pour le match de mardi parce
que j'ai jou le match de mardi en ProB
céta pour voil retrouver mes sensations
et voir ce
que que je va aller sur les joueuses de
ce niveau et ça s bien passé Anne Sophie
s'incline en 8e de finale face à la tête
de série numéro 2 Caro grich grâce à
cette performance la pongiste et
l'ctoise devra voir les championnats de
France au printemps prochain le
critérium permettait de sortir du
quotidien du championnat mais pas
question de galvoder la compétition pour
autant se faire plaisir j'ai envie de
dire oui et non quoi je dire le le but
c'est quand même d'arriver ici en étant
bien bien dans dans sa forme et puis de
jouer le mieux possible ouais c'est sûr
que si on arrive crisp ici ça passera
pas quoi la tension semble avoir envahi
la jeune audrearif l'espoir ivlinoise
faisait pourtant partie des favorites
chez les juniors mais elle n'a pas passé
la première journée les chances de
victoire reposaient à sur la solide
yanang mais les lancourtoises s'incline
en demi-finale face à la vainqueur du
tournoi yangong zogin les joueuses de
Franck solniier peuvent désormais se
replonger dans leur priorités le
championnat de France de probé allez on
passe au résultats du
[Applaudissements]
weekend en football si en Division
d'Honneur la rencontre entre Boulogne
billancour et Versailles a été reportée
en promotion d'honneur cela a joué vous
le voyez mais ça le weekend pour les
clubs cinquantinois dans le choc de la
poule B entre le leader nanè et trappe
5e ce sont les Nanterriens qui se sont
imposés 20 de son côté guyancour
toujours en courant alternatif cette
saison c'est également incliné à
saintclou 3-0 chez les femmes football
féminin les Amazon deslancour ont
remporté le duel des mal classés à
Argenteuil les joueuses de danygle
s'imposent 3-1 et remontent à la 6e
place de leur Pol de Promotion d'Honneur
en handball 9e journée de National de
féminine Montini a réalisé la perf du
weekend en s'imposant à domicile face au
leader Gagny avec la manière en plus
2519 les inimontaines sont toujours 7e
au classement basket national une
féminine 11e journée l'entente le chîn
et versaill n'a rien pu faire sur le
parquet du 2e hnois défaites de 18
points 75 à 57 les filles de Stéphane
Rolly restent englué à la 10e place chez
les hommes aucune victoire ce weekend
malheureusement traape 8èe s'incline à
domicile face au ministère des Finances
68 à 63 et le LCV perd le derby évlinois
face à poissi 76 à 59 et reste 10e comme
les femmes en volleyball 7e journée de
régional une montinny recevait vcen au
complexe Pierre de Coubertin ce dimanche
et c'était un petit peu chacun son tour
dans ce match après un premier sa de
gagner difficilement 25-23 les joueurs
d'abdellaatif nichli marque le pas dans
la seconde manche qu'il perd 25-18 mais
il réagissent et remporte le 3e 2522
avant à nouveau de concéder un autre 7
25 17 et c'est dans finalement dans la
5e manche décisive que les inimontains
vont finir par s'imposer 15 6 37 à 2
donc Montini reste 6e de sa poule de
régional une rugby 9e journée de
championnat territorial d'honneur on
suit évidemment le Sky rugby et 9e
défaite malheureusement pour les
cinantinois sur la pelouse de garechevau
crosson 45 à 6 les matchs se suivent et
se ressemble pour le Sky rugby
rollerquet évidemment on suit les chocs
d'élancours en 6e journée de National 2
même sort pour les les chocs 8e à
flamandville 7e ils s'incline 6-3 cette
fois-ci ils n'ont toujours pas remporté
le moindre match match cette saison et
reste lanterne rouge de leur poule
encore quelques infos avant de conclure
ce 7 H8 sport tout d'abord une petite
info football décalé ce weekend de
nombreuses villes cquantinoises étaient
mobilisé pour le Téléton c'était
notamment le cas à Manil et amamo la
mobilisation manicoise était parrainée
par l'ancien gardien de l'AS Monaco et
de l'équipe de France Jean-Luc etori
dont on a beaucoup parlé hein ces
derniers temps pour son record battu de
602 matchs joué en Ligue 1 par Michel
Landre le portier de Bastia nous avons
recueilli son impression au micro de
Michel jar pas du tout tenu 20 ans et et
je dirais qu'aujourd'hui on en parle
tellement que quelque part les qualités
qu'on prête à Mika ben j'en prends un
peu pour moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
sera jamais battu donc je sais qu'il se
pose des questions quand à la suite de
sa carrière en fin de saison donc
réfléchis bien Mika tout simplement
toujours en football mais cette fois-ci
on part pour les États-Unis pourquoi
parce que ce weekend le Sporting Kansas
City a remporté le championnat de MLS
l'équivalent de la Ligue 1 en France en
oututreatlantique en battant en finale
sauteleake City au tir au but et et dans
cette équipe de Cana sévolu un ivelinois
Aurélien Collin a grandi à Fontenel
Fleury il a même marqué l'unique but de
son équipe lors de la finale et a été
desésé MVP comprenait meilleur joueur de
la finale une dernière info pour
terminer du tennis fauteuil cette
semaine se déroulaient les championnat
de France de tennis fauteuil à saint-je
viev des boois dans les sones première
série il est leurom bolittin que vous
voyez à l'image Johan killou était en
lise pas verni hein par le tirage au
sort livelinois hérité d'une poule très
difficile en compagnie des deux
meilleurs joueurs français C Fanou et
Frédéric cateno Johan termine ses
championnats à la 7e place finalement
dernier Act d'une saison qu'il a vu
entrer dans le top 30 mondial avant de
nous quitter évidemment la jadin du
weekend de petites dates à retenir ce
samedi du baby basket à Guill encour
plateau de baby basket organisé par le
club guyan courtois au gymnase des
droits de l'homme rendez-vous entre 14h
et 17h pour voir la relève de Tony
Parker et du tir à l'arc tout le weekend
manche qualificativ pour les
championnats de France rendez-vous au
gymnase Maurice Baquet samedi à partir
de 13h30 et dimanche entre 8h 30 et 19h
c'est la fin de ce 78 sport merci encore
une fois de l'avoir suivi n'hésitez pas
à le commenter he sur les réseaux
sociaux et Twitter avec le hashtag le 78
sport tout attaché d'ici là excellente
soirée sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
TVfil